let's talk about miracle workers this
what I love about this is it's a really
fun depiction of heaven as kind of a
chaotic place not a place that is
well-run and ordered no I mean it was
very important to Simon in in building
this world that we have a representation
of heaven and the afterlife that is is
consistent with what we see on earth and
earth is chaotic and messy and crazy
so if Heaven was sort of very well
ordered and run very smoothly you kind
of be going where okay where is the
disconnect so yeah so we have a heaven
that is a corporation that exists to run
the earth which is being run by by Steve
Buscemi as God who is also yeah can say
Steve Buscemi as guard
yeah perfect I mean really perfect and
it when I when I say to you like there
are a lot of his scenes I wasn't there
for on set and iíve been like while I
was watching this series I am crying
laughing with the stuff he's doing it's
just it's it's amazing and yeah it's
just this it's incredibly I think funny
very capable of show it's capable of it
being very very dark in its humor but
also there's ultimately like which there
isn't all of Simon's writing I think
like a kindness and a sweetness and
others obvious sweetness of characters
that hopefully is really just makes it
really enjoyable for people to watch
it's terrific we have a clip here from
miracle workers and I think this is
where you and yeah I know worker we are
we are expiring axis Geraldine
Viswanathan yeah this one - I'm still
like bad at pronouncing Hasani but she's
she's amazing she's good at she was in
blockers last year she just had a movie
at Sundance and she's she's amazing and
it's gonna be a big star okay I think
this is you too
she's working hard to try and engineer
something to happen on earth yeah which
i think is more difficult and we are
trying to get two very very shy awkward
human beings to kiss and that is that is
a lot of the through line of the show in
order to save the world these two people
will have to kiss this is what I mean
it's a very sweet story as well as
thousands dying those are the stakes ya
know and but yes so it's this is us
conspiring to get these two people to
meet and hopefully kiss what's they over
this clip from miracle workers
I figured it out we can get salmon Lord
together we just need to engineer a
chance encounter Oh No those are very
risky check it out they both live near
the same hospital so all we need to do
is get them there at the same time step
one injure Laura I found a melon near an
open window along her route to work we
blow it off it clunks are on the head
and she goes straight to the ER with Sam
I figure we just pop his appendix they
spot each other in the ER sparks fly
they kiss world saves okay it's very I
don't I don't know though oh don't worry
appendices are easy look there's even a
button for it it's a very funny show
miracle-workers airs Tuesdays at 10:30
right here on TBS Daniel Radcliffe it's
just a joy when you're here
[Applause]